as a matter of fact the universe always
existed
and what we believe was the beginning
was just a transition from a contracting
face to an expanding phase that we call
the bands
the big band's idea can explain certain
features of the universe that the
big bang idea that there was a beginning
cannot
singularity is not a good feature it's a
sign of some sickness
[Music]
so peter i'm guessing you are familiar
with
the big bang theory well i think you're
talking about the
12-year running uh emmy award-winning
cbs
comedy the big bang theory but uh i'm
not i haven't
actually i never actually watched that
show but i am a huge fan
of uh young sheldon which is i guess the
story before
sheldon became sheldon but i don't know
any of the characters
uh sheldon nor i mean i obviously know
sheldon but i don't know anything about
the big set no i don't know anything jim
parsons the guy that plays sheldon who
actually sort of became the star of that
show
uh and like you mentioned 12 years it
was the number one
sitcom i wasn't i didn't watch it
religiously i did
you know i'm familiar with the storyline
and obviously they dealt with
with throughout the show some of the top
names in fizz neil degrasse tyson made
appearances
bill nye of course famously uh made
appearances on the big bang theory
and we're lucky enough to get some of
the luminaries of the world of physics
and science join us here on what if
discussed
but yes it wasn't talking about the show
i was talking about the actual big
the big bang theory yes i mean the thing
that the universe
started from uh pea-sized singularity
14 billion years ago give or take 100
million years and
we're here now expanding from that uh
from that explosion yes that's what they
say
uh and again one of the things that we
forget
in that title of both the sitcom and
what you're talking about
is the word theory we we often sort of
just take it for granted that this is an
absolute of course
these things are always changing they're
always being revised nobody was there
at the time nobody i i haven't seen a
video um
so like science it's always evolving
it's changing when we figure new things
out we develop new technologies
and this is no different and of course
now the big bang theory i'm not saying
it's on its way out
but it's certainly being challenged now
by
theories that are that answer some of
the questions the big bang theory didn't
like the big bounce theory and cyclical
universe theory
the big bounce theory meaning that we
are bouncing
not like a bungee cord or a yoga ball
or a basketball um but yes i mean
there is some sort of contraction and
uh or expansion and contraction thing
going on again well
so it's like one of those uh paddle ball
things yes
well this is the type of explanation you
get when you and i try to break it down
so i'll give you two
options you could we could either
continue this
or you could actually hear the
explanation from
probably the preeminent person on the
planet working on
the big bounce theory right now i'm i'm
curious to continue with this and see
how you
you are going to explain yes well this
i i she is she is a theoretical
physicist
i am a theoretical theoretical physicist
and i think in the end probably option a
would be the the
place where we're gonna more answers
theoretically theoretically
on fire today um so our guest today
for what if the universe
was bouncing is well it's dr
anna iash a theoretical physicist
working in gravitation and cosmology
at the max planck institute for
gravitational physics in germany
her research is aimed at the most
fundamental questions about the universe
what is the mechanism that created our
universe what is the universe composed
of and
how will it be changing in the future
before joining the max planck society
dr eosh held the inaugural john a
wheeler post doctoral fellowship at the
princeton center for theoretical
science and spent the following two
years as a research faculty and
principal investigator of the origins of
the universe initiative
at the columbia center for theoretical
physics and
harvard's institute for theory and
computation
dr iash thanks for joining us today on
what if discussed
oh it's great to be here thanks richard
so uh
not a small question obviously how did
the universe form
uh what is the origin of the universe
and
one could be forgiven for believing that
oh we've already figured that out
right i mean religion for years kind of
had so many people think they have
different origin theories on kind of how
we arrived here and then science kind of
took over
uh you know four or five hundred years
ago ultimately culminating in the big
bang theory being kind of
what we've sort of all agreed on is the
origins of the universe but theory
is really the key word in the sentence
and there's still a lot of
to be determined especially with your
work kind of looking at it differently
so i'll
i'll ask the question this way uh dr
yesh
in the beginning there was what
um no beginning excellent but
but when i believe is that instead of a
bank
that actually was a bounce and these
bands took us from a phase of
contraction before to a phase of
expansion after
and this expansion is still lasting so
we are currently an expanding phase
and the cool idea is here that all the
features of the universe
so the distribution of matter its
geometry that we see today
um all traced back and over generated
during this phase and the universe
contracted down to small size and
bounced back to our current expanding
phase
so we tend to always think of things in
uh in a dualism
manner you know it's an it's an either
or for most of the things that we uh
think of like uh king kong versus
uh godzilla or batman versus superman
or superman yeah one or the other so
but uh with the big bang theory versus
the big
bounce theory it sounds like you can't
have one without the other am i right
um no i would disagree these are really
two distinct ideas
so the one idea the big band theory says
that space and time really had a
beginning
and since this beginning it's always
been expanding and always will be
expanding
and the other idea the the idea of there
being a big bounce
preceding or expanding phase says no
there was no beginning
as a matter of fact the universe always
existed and what we believed was the
beginning was just a transition
from a contracting face to an expanding
phase that we call the bands
so not only that these two ideas are
competing
they are really incompatible and the
struggle is to figure out
which one is the right idea so was there
a beginning or was there no beginning
but a bands
and we are in a fortunate situation
today that we actually can figure this
out
both using our mathematics using our
computers all
simulations and using experiment and as
a matter of fact i would say
recent work that i have done together
with collaborator has shown that
the big band's idea can explain certain
features of the universe that the
big bang idea that there was a beginning
cannot
hmm so it's more about the infinite
versus the finite
i guess to some degree right some degree
it's true yes
well that's i mean it's hard to get your
head around and it's interesting because
you hear
you know the cyclical universe theory
which
sounds i guess closer to what you're
talking about and
maybe is more compatible with bounce
because it's
there is no beginning it's it's kind of
going in and out
i've heard it explained kind of again
expanding in contraction
we've heard about the big crunch theory
which
would i guess you'd have quite the
six-pack
as a universe if there was a lot of
crunches but in that regard
if it's expanding and contracting
bouncing if you will in a cycle
then i mean it sounds almost like
breathing is that is that a fair at the
macro sense it's almost like
inhaling and exhaling it's not quite
like that
you are right that earlier almost all
ideas that involve the
cyclic universe where the universe
underwent infinite periods of
contraction and expansion
connected by a band people really
thought that it was more like breathing
but that's not true for the kind of new
new kind of psychic ideas
that i'm exploring together with my
group so
in the old idea what you are quoting is
people told that
after the bands the universe was
expanding by a certain amount
and then contracted by the same amount
but what we think today is that instead
what happens is
that the universe expands a lot more
than it contracts
and this is quite cool because it turns
out that all the problems of the earlier
ideas related to the fact
that people thought of the universe as a
six-pack but
if you make the universe expand a lot
more then
then it contracts then you can solve all
the problems with the old cyclic models
and end up with a universe that keeps
growing growing and growing and the only
reason
by why we don't see in a cyclic universe
that's the case is because we are local
observers
and so the observer would think this is
just like breathing but it's not the
case
the the singularity or the primeval atom
that they sometimes call it
is a big part of the big bang theory the
big
bounce gets criticized for bypassing the
singularity
um how can we understand that piece of
the puzzle
well that's perhaps uh misunderstanding
because you know singularity is not a
good feature
usually when a theory that we have in
physics
has a singularity then we consider it as
a problem
it is a sign of some sickness it's sign
it's the sign that the theory breaks
down when it encounters a singularity
so actually what people have been trying
to do even in the context of the big
bang theory
to explain the beginning without the
singularity without this sickness
and i personally and i would say my
colleagues to consider
uh the absence of a singularity a real
advantage of the big bang's theory you
can cure the sickness of there being a
singularity by eliminating the bank and
replacing it by advance
i like the uh the sickness idea of it
because i mean to be honest
it's it wouldn't be the first time that
somebody brought up the the big bang
theory in my life where i was like so
let me get this straight
you're saying that the all the energy in
the universe came from a pea-sized
singularity
sounds about right and uh kind of what
be and but the obvious follow-up has
always been
well what became what came before the
singularity and generally speaking
people have been like well
we we don't know which to your point is
the breakdown in the theory
you're somebody that also has an
interest in the philosophy of science
you've studied it you've written about
it
and this feels to me where we get into a
little more
philosophically even esoteric because
for the finite human being
with our dualistic minds small dualistic
small dualistic minds
the idea of infinity is just an
abstraction it's so hard to get our
heads around
yet it's a key piece of this puzzle
how do we how do we know this let's call
it the unknowable and how do we
how do we understand infinity
okay that's a tough one
because you know the question is if it's
important to understand it
in in the history of physics in
particular during the last hundred years
we have encountered situations when we
just couldn't understand or imagine
things that turned out to be true
so take for example quantum physics it's
really difficult to understand or
imagine
that a single electron can go through
several slits
right at the same time and behaves like
a wave
we don't understand it we don't really
imagine it
but what turns out is that in the in
physics we very often encounter
situations when
we have to live with things we have to
accept things but
we previously told not to be true not to
be imaginable
and i believe it is it is similar with
the universe you know
if an experiment or if if we invent
theories that tell us that the universe
might be infinite
and we find experiments that show us
that that really is the better
explanation than
assuming a finite universe then we
probably will first have to live with it
without truly
understanding or or imagining it just by
the way that that's the better
explanation
uh being taught us by experiment so this
is a strange situation
yeah and it's it's like a lot of you
know you hear about some people talking
about
no time and space and although i can say
okay i can i can understand what you
mean
but i can't understand no time and space
like it just feels like something that's
such a
an integral part of this existence but
the lack of time is just something so
abstract for our human minds or at least
my human mind
i am in space there is time yes i i
would say as well
but these are obviously uh some bigger
questions which we will
we will follow up with you uh after we
take a little break here because there's
there's certainly more to get to um but
we really i mean thanks for taking us
through this particular
in the beginning scenario or at least
one
of the scenarios of in the beginning
where can people follow your work right
now
and what do you have coming up because
it sounds like you're on the cusp of
some
pretty big game-changing theories
i hope so certainly uh this is pretty
simple
so we we have a website my group has a
website it is also simple it's called
dancingcosmology.com onward
and there you find me my bio links to my
personal website
um the people i work with and their
descriptions
are papers that they put out and perhaps
most interesting for
for for the viewers uh is that we have
there was a
links to videos and videos uh that some
of them are
quite accessible for for people
who don't every day and every night work
on the balancing universe
like like like peter and i yeah yeah
thank you small brain people
um well if you liked this episode and i
don't know why you wouldn't
yeah maybe you'd like to dig a little
bit deeper and you can
because we're going to go a little bit
deeper on our extended audio
podcast yes which i am and who knows by
the end of this we might have
we might have figured out uh how the
universe started
and perhaps more importantly where is
the universe going
maybe we're on the cusp of of solving it
feels like we are but
uh you know probably in the next 20
minutes we'll probably just scratch the
surface
uh dr ishas thanks for joining us today
on what if discussed
thanks very much thanks
so uh yeah wow i don't know where to
start
that's well you can't know where to
start because as dr yash says there's no
beginning
and there is no end that is perfect
which again
it's really hard to get your head around
uh and i i learned a lot and i love
i love how she describes what she's
working on but there's a reason why
there's only a few people in the world
that
are working on these types of things
because they have the minds that can
sort of
even deal with the infinite me on the
other hand
it ends up being kind of more questions
than answers
yeah well uh here's the good thing is
that we have more questions
and we'll get more answers on the other
side on the other side if you like this
interview and you want to
learn more maybe you want to learn
infinitely more maybe you want to
contract a little bit and not learned
something you're on fire either way
why don't you click on the link below
and uh that'll take you to the extended
audio version now if you're already
listening to the extended audio version
don't go looking for a link because
there is no link
just keep listening just keep listening
that's all there is to it
uh we'd like to thank dr iash again and
please join us again next week
on what if discussed